in recent years artificial intelligence
and machine learning have permeated
every aspect of Our Lives if you are a
programmer chances are you have begun
utilizing github's co-pilot an AI tool
that transforms natural language PRS
into coding suggestions streamlining the
programming process as a writer you may
have encountered open AIS G F3 or
similar Auto regressive language models
that leverage deep learning to generate
text resembling human language many of
has dedicated a few hours to
experimenting with d 2 the AIML power
text to image generator capable of
producing intricate visuals based on the
most unusual request not only is d 2
exponentially more powerful but it also
has the potential to revolutionize the
field of digital art consider its impact
on a digit digital artist illustrator or
graphic designer career imagine creating
a highly realistic image within seconds
using an app these technologies have
significant real world applications with
far-reaching implications let me tell
you some fascinating facts about machine
learning according to recent studies
machine learning related job postings
have increased bi a staggering 344 per
in the past 5 years companies across the
globe are actively seeking professionals
who can harness the power of data and
build intelligence systems the average
salary is
$190,000 in us and 26 lakhs perom in
India accelerate your career in Ai and
ml with our comprehensive postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning gain
expertise in machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
alumni membership and hackathons and ask
me anything sessions by IBM with three
Capstone and and 25 plus industry
projects using real data sets from
Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts ensure
Top Notch education simply learns job
assist helps you get noticed by Leading
companies live sessions on AI trends
like chat GPT generative Ai and
explainable AI this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural
networks computer vision G caras
tensorflow and many more skills enroll
now and unlock exciting a ml
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below with that
having said now here is a comprehensive
step by-step guide to learning machine
learning number one is skills required
number two job rolls in ml number third
compan is hiring ml engineers and the
number four is future scope of ml now
starting with the number one that is
fundamentals of machine learning
familiarize yourself with the
fundamentals of machine learning in the
initial stages of learning to drive we
are familiarized with the different
elements varieties and regulations
pertaining to operating a car it is
essential to delve into the fundamentals
of machine learning to understand what
lies ahead and the required knowledge
now moving to number two that is
acquiring Proficiency in python or our
programming language to excel in the
field of artificial intelligence and
machine learning it is crucial to
develop a strong command of python or R
programming language both Python and R
are widely used in the data science
Community due to their versatility and
extensive libraries for scientific
Computing so now moving on to the third
step that is gain knowledge of essential
python libraries for machine learning
once you have acquired Proficiency in
python as part of our machine Learning
Journey the subsequent step involves
familiarizing yourself with essential
python libraries crucial for working
with data and implementing machine
learning Solutions the key python
libraries that you should learn from
machine learning are numpy pandas
matplot lip and psyit Lear now moving to
step four that is learn and Implement
various machine learning algorithms
after gaining Proficiency in python as
part of our machine Learning Journey the
subsequent Milestone involves learning
various machine learning algorithms and
their implementation using python listed
below are some of the key machine
learning algorithms that are essential
to learning number one linear regression
number two logistic regression number
three passive aggression number four
Nave Base number five support Vector
machines now moving to step five Master
the concepts and implementation of
neural networks once you have acquired
knowledge of python and machine learning
algorithms the next significant step in
the machine learning road map is to
learn neural network architecture and
their implementations using python
outlined below are several crucial
neural network architectures that are
essential to learning number one
artificial neural networks number two
CNN number three
RNN number four long shortterm memory
now moving to step six that is engage
Hands-On projects to apply your
knowledge and reinforce your
understanding after acquiring knowledge
of python machine learning algorithms
and neural network architectures the
next crucial step is the machine
learning road map and is to gain
practical experience by working on
projects that allow you to apply what
you have learned the first project is
Iris flower classification number two
California house price prediction number
three stock price prediction number four
customer segmentation now we'll move to
job roles in machine learning machine
learning as highlighted earlier has
gained immense popularity for its
ability to elevate human efforts and and
enhance machine performance through
autonomous learning this popularity has
resulted in lucrative and sought after
career options within the field
including roles like machine learning
engineer so the duty of a machine
learning engineer encompasses the
creation construction and deployment of
machine learning models collaborating
closely with data scientist and software
Engineers they participate in the
development and execution of machine
Learning Systems according to glasto ml
engineers can earn up to
$150,000 in us and 11 lakhs perom in
India now moving to data scientist the
role of a data scientist involves
Gathering scrutinizing and interpreting
extensive data sets leveraging machine
learning algorithms they uncover
patterns and glean insights from the
data utilizing this knowledge to inform
decisions and address challenges
according to glasto data scientist earn
$145,000 in US and13 laks perom in India
now moving to NLP Engineers the specific
duties may vary based on the role and
sector but as outlined by freelancer map
an NLP engineer typically engage in
tasks such as designing natural language
processing systems and addressing speech
patterns and AI speech recognition
according to glassor NLP engineer can
earn
$120,000 in us and 10 lakhs perom in
India now moving to computer Vision
engineer Engineers specializing in
computer vision operate within the realm
of computer vision employing machine
learning to empower computers to
comprehend and interpret visual data
from their surroundings the
responsibilities include tasks such as
image and video analysis and object
detection according to glasto CV
Engineers earn
$16,000 in us and 8 lakhs perom in India
now moving to business intelligence
development ER the main role of a bi
developer is to develop deploy and
maintain bi tools and interfaces they
are also responsible for simplifying
highly technical language and complex
information into layman's terms for
everyone else in the company to
understand according to Glass Ro
business intelligence developers earn
$15,000 in us and 7 lakhs perom in India
now we'll see the top companies hiring
for machine learning engineer number one
is Amazon
then we have asenta Google Apple Intel
so these are the top hiring companies
that hire machine learning Engineers now
we'll talk about future of machine
learning machine learning has a bright
future but faces several difficulties ml
is predicted to grow increasingly
pervasive as technology develops
revolutionizing sectors including
Healthcare Banking and transportation
the work Market will change due to AI
driven automation necessary in new
position and skills and with this we
have come to the end of this video I
hope you found this video informative
and interesting if you like this video
give us a thumbs up and share it with
your friends also if you have any
questions about this video please feel
free to ask in the comment section below
our team will get back to you as soon as
possible and our courses covered in this
video link will be provided in the
description box below do check them out
thank you and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations
and delivered by industry experts choose
any of our programs and set yourself on
the path to Career Success click the
link in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here